es el primer periodista occidental
encarcelado desde el golpe de estado
declarado culpable por incitación al
delito por tener contacto con
organizaciones ilegales y por violar las
normas del visado cuando fue detenido en
mayo el periodista danny fenster se
dirigía a su casa para visitar a su
familia en eeuu todos estos cargos se
basan en la alegación de que trabajaba
para mí and mark now un medio de
comunicación prohibido no hay
absolutamente ninguna base para condenar
a danny por estos cargos su equipo
jurídico demostró claramente al tribunal
que había renunciado a mianmar now y que
trabajaba para frontier desde mediados
del año pasado todo el mundo en frontier
está decepcionado y frustrado por esta
decisión el gobierno de eeuu ha estado
presionando para la liberación de
fenster mientras que los grupos de
derechos humanos han dicho que el caso
está pensado para intimidar a los
periodistas desde el golpe de estado en
febrero la junta militar de mianmar ha
reprimido duramente a los críticos con
el gobierno las autoridades mataron a
más de 1200 civiles en las protestas y
detuvieron a miles según naciones unidas
ellos decenas de periodistas razón por
la que el alta comisionada de derechos
humanos de la onu michelle bachelet
pidió su liberación inmediata a partir
de esta semana danny fenster enfrentará
a una serie de cargos adicionales bajo
la ley de terrorismo del país por la que
podría ser condenado con hasta 20 años
de prisión